everybody talks about alzheimer's and
dementia as if it's a disease that just
starts at one point
you know you are diagnosed with
alzheimer's disease there that's it
that's not the start
right before that you know decades
earlier there is a
continuous cognitive decline that people
experience
and you know dean and i go to different
communities for talks and before all
this
pandemic when you go into communities
where
you know their their health literacy is
lower for example they haven't had any
resources
you actually experience the cognitive
decline when speaking with individuals
in their 50s and 60s
before they even are diagnosed with
alzheimer's disease and
it's it's scary and the numbers are
scary
and we never address that and it's not
just
brain health you know you you hear about
brain health all the time you hear
you read great books but it's that
self that is under attack it's that um
us it's that us-ness you know it's it's
the
sense of uh being aware and being
present
and being able to uh experience life
that is we're being robbed of that um
you hear brain fog
you hear memory problems but not being
able to
be present for each and every moment in
your life that's what's taken away from
people and that's scary
and if we have a way of making
people attuned where we alarm them that
listen there is
something that you can do where you
don't have to go through this
i think that would be a great uh
opportunity and it's a great gift for us
to be able to serve people that way
right so conventional medical
wisdom at least until recently
is or was that alzheimer's is something
that
is going to be visited upon many many
people when they reach
i don't know late 60s 70s something like
that
it's basically a genetic predisposition
in more cases than not it's a death
sentence there's not much we can do
about it
we can't cure it we can't prevent it
we can kind of maybe manage it with some
drugs but
really there isn't much that we can do
and we're working on a cure but we
aren't very close
so how much of that is accurate and
where does your work fit in to kind of
upend that paradigm
so the genetic component let's start
with that we know the genes that are
involved
in alzheimer's with new techniques like
g was analysis and others where you take
large populations who have alzheimer's
and those that don't
you look at the genetic differences we
know about more than 30 genes that are
involved in alzheimer's
of all alzheimer's cases the percentage
that's driven
by genes 100 dry driven by genes meaning
that if they have these genes they will
get it
and and and genetic terms it's called
100 penetrants like huntington's disease
if a person has the huntington gene on
that chromosome 4 they'll get it right
but the percentage of alzheimer's cases
are that are like that
is only up to three percent the other 97
are affected by genes but they're they
are only
risk genes meaning that those genes
increase your risk
but they're not a foregone conclusion it
doesn't me
it doesn't mean that you will get it the
the next highest risk gene
is apoe4 about
two percent of population has eight four
is eighty four positive
so if you have one of those genes coming
from one parent
your risk goes up four times if you have
two one from each parent about 12 times
that number varies but roughly those are
the numbers so even if you have two
genes
fully loaded with these bad genes fifty
percent of people get the disease
the other fifty percent don't get it why
and when you look at the data coming
from nigeria where the population had
higher
proclavity for apoe when they came to us
then disease went up
when you look at the studies that came
from uk which
lifestyle increased your risk six times
even
in lieu of april e4 you realize
even with the higher genetic risk of
apoe4
lifestyle is a way bigger factor by far
so all of the genes involved in
alzheimer's except for those
three percent or three genes are
all our lifestyle genes
how your lifestyle affects those genes
which means you have control over it
even the most benign studies
the ones that had minimal effect the
mind study and others
mind study just looked at diet very well
done study
just a diet adjustment
reduced your risk of alzheimer's by 53
wow and that was a watered-down version
of the diet we think
is optimal how
how long would you need to be you know
eating and
eating in that certain way leading up to
it it varies from person to person their
their background other things like if
they had multiple head traumas
uh childbirth like multiple variables
but in reality
if you're on that diet for several years
you continually reduce your risk like
smoking if you've smoked all your life
and if you come off of smoking come off
of that bacon
and come off of that you know uh well
let's then
the more years you pass i believe in
smoking it's after
five years five to seven years seven
years you're back to baseline right
meaning that you're back to the lowest
risk factor
um so the longer you stay on a healthy
lifestyle which is exercise and
and all the things that we say and
especially if you do all of them
the reason i say all of them let's
coming back to our grandparents
one of the elements is cognitive reserve
or
what the term you and i love idea
density
you know we say that if we have a
musical band that's going to be called
idea density they had idea density yes
it's a great great um concept they both
both our grandparents had
immense idea density and and
philosophers think
but they succumbed to alzheimer's why
the other elements weren't taken care of
they
had diabetes cholesterol high blood
pressure quite sedentary
bad food didn't exercise philosophers
are not supposed to exercise for some
reason
but so you have to do all of it
[Music]
you